hey everyone its micromotor flows and I
wanna tell you about a webinar I got
coming up on Friday August 3rd 2018 and
it's in conjunction with investor
inspiration I'm gonna be talking about
what you need to know about order flow
and the sign-up link is in the
description below and it'll take you to
this page you just enter your name and
email address and you can see I'm the
first speaker on this day I start
speaking at 10 a.m. Eastern time there's
a total of six speakers that day so I'm
the first one to kick it off now what
I'll be talking about is what is the
most important part of order flow you
know for many people they find order
flow is that missing piece to the
trading puzzle that helps them finally
get over that hurdle and become a
consistent profitable trader and we
talked about the new developments in
order flow analysis now you know order
flow has been around for a long time and
you know who are the innovators who's
innovating in the order flow analysis
field and you know there's a lot of
other software out there that it just
basically gives you the the
run-of-the-mill volume footprint chart
which is you know okay but you know what
there's ways to use the computer to
further your analysis of it I'll be
talking about that and I'm talking about
why you don't need to predict the future
to be a successful trader you know if
you read these older trading books you
go to the library you know sometimes
they got these old trading books written
you know 20 30 40 50 years ago and
always talking about how to how to
predict the future how to predict you
know where the markets gonna go you
don't need to do that you know just
listen to what the market is telling you
and trade it you know that brings me up
to the fourth point you know stop
waiting for confirmation and start
trading you know a lot of times I see
traders you know they pull out their
charts and they're like well you know we
got this thing for me notice this
formation forming and I wait for
confirmation then you know all the trade
well meanwhile the market is trading
back and forth and you know they're just
sitting there on the sidelines you know
it's like do you want to be in the game
or do just want to be waiting for the
coach to call you up right and you know
sometimes you're waiting for
confirmation and it just never comes and
you know and meanwhile life is going by
you know markets moving and you're not
taking any trades so you know I want to
show you how order flow can help you
with that and you know again you know
register for the webinar the link is in
the description below it's free if you
can't attend that's fine as long as
you're registered you know get access to
the replay when it's available and you
know you're definitely going to learn
something
either from me or from some of the other
speakers you know some of the other
speakers will be talking about options
you know I know a lot of people are
interested in options and you know that
I said there's there's five other
speakers this day so surely you can
learn something from one of them you
know if not me hopefully you'll like my
presentation and find it useful so
thanks everyone and hope to see you
there on Friday bye bye